wir schützen jeder von euch und ihr
deutsche mussen nicht vergessen ein Teil
von Deutschland in Kranke Vision gota
und russische imperie auch D der meine
ich kämpfen gegen eine der stärkste und
mächtigste Armee in der Welt russische
Armee und seit Z Jahren wir verteidigen
unser Land erfolgreich verteidigen
unseres Land weil Putin hat seine Pläne
nicht realisiert wirdine Überlebende
Krieg oder nicht wirdine existieren oder
nicht in in den Zeit noch dazu für eine
Position zu kämpfen das ist chuldung
Dummheit man muss kämpfen für seine
Vision für sein Zukunft für seine
Familie für für sein Land das machen wir
wir nehmen an diesem Morgen den
Hintereingang zum Rathaus hier sind wir
mit vital klitchko verabredet dem
Bürgermeister von Kiev meine ukrainische
Kollegin alexandraucha und ich sind
nicht zum ersten Mal hier aber jedes Mal
aufs Neue such wir den Weg es ist
erstaunlich
ruhig vitalie klitchko schaut kurz
herein während wir für das Interview
aufbauen wir brauchen noch Stühle und
der ehemalige Profiboxer packt sofort
mit an sehr gut wir können das
machen super vielen Dank dann wackeln
wir nicht so ich schie ihn
einfach sie können so lange machen wie
sie wollen wir haben Zeit Erinnerungen
an den Boxweltmeister aus dem ein
Bürgermeister im Krieg wurde das Kämpfen
hat nie aufgehört jetzt tut er es vor
allem für sein Land wir haben uns ja
habe ich mal rausgesucht 2014 schon
kennengelernt und danach sind wir uns
auch öfter noch mal begegnet im
ukrainischen Haus will Alisa den
Oppositionsführer Vitali klitchko sehen
er ist einer der weitere Gewalt
verhindern will wir reden ja auch viel
mit Politikern aber auch mit Menschen in
Deutschland haben Sie das
Gefühl dass wir noch verstehen was hier
passiert dass wir noch genug Anteil
nehmen ist schwierig ist schwierig zu
verstehen einfach von Bildschirm zu
sehen man bekommt nicht die ganze
Emotionen die ganze Verständnis was
wirklich in noine los ist wenn man fährt
nach Osten und man sieht die leere
Dörfer leere Städte leere Fenster und
hinter jede leere Fenster eine
Familie als flüchinge und wenn man kommt
rein in die Gebäude und MAN SE man sieht
die Leute hat die ganze Leben lang
gearbeitet und Sachen gesammelt hat
Pläne gehabt hat alles gelassen und äh
jetzt im Moment irgendwo abdachlos nicht
und man muss auch nie vergessen eine
große Teil von Menschen in diese Dorfe
oder Städte sind gestorben jetzt sind
wir gerade in einer Situation wo wir
zumindest wirkt das von außen so einen
innenpolitischen Machtkampf in der
Ukraine Erleben der uns doch alle ein
bisschen erstaunt können Sie mir
beschreiben was hier gerade passiert
m meine mal meine Meinung nach eine
Wettkampf politische Wettkampf in das
Land was befindet sich in Krieg das ist
eine riesige große fle für jede
Politiker gibt keinen Sinn einen
Wettkampf zu machen zum eine Position zu
kämpfen weil heute die Frage steht ganz
scharf wirdine Überlebende Krieg oder
nicht wirdine existieren oder nicht in
den Zeit noch dazu für eine Position zu
kämpfen das ist Entschuldigung Dummheit
man dürfte nicht ein WL in Krieg zu
machen das gibt viele Fragen wie können
wir unsere wellle zählen weil ist kein
Geheimnis 9 Millionen von Menschen
aushhalb der ine befinden sich eine
ungefähr genau gleiche Zahl Flüchtlinge
in das Land eine große Teil von Menschen
hat Militäruniform genommen und Waffen
die Handy und kämpfen jetzt im Moment in
Frontlinie wir haben leider mehr Frage
als Antworten und noch dazu eine
politische Wettbewerb eine politische
Wettkampf wann kämpfen wir mit
gegen Russland das eine Gift für das
Land das kann kan kann Land von innen
zerstören und deswegen ich bin fest
überzeugt solange das Krieg
läuft eine politische Wettbewerb in in
duukine das ist eine riesige Fälle also
sollte es auch keine Wahlen ihrer
Meinung geben jetzt jetzt im Moment
muss kein Wahl werden werieg in das Land
und gleichzeitig wir brauchen sehr viel
Ressourcen Wahl zu machen und wir haben
nicht genug Ressourcen einfach unsere
Soldaten zu unterstüzen
deswegen solange das Krieg
läuft die wah wird eine das Wal wird
eine große fle wir haben bevor wir das
Interview mit Ihnen hier angefragt haben
auch mal unsere Zuschauer fragt was die
denn interessiert was möchten die von
von Ihnen wissen also z.B eine Frage war
dass einer unserer Zuschauer fragt sind
die Menschen in der Ukraine immer noch
so motiviert wie am Anfang des Krieges
für ihr Land zu kämpfen gegen Russland
zu kämpfen meine Antwort ja die Menschen
sehr sehr motiviert und sogar
Umfragen wir machen ganz often Umfragen
gemacht was sollen wir machen kämpfen
oder auf aufgeben für Russland und mehr
als 90% sagen nein auf keinen Fall wir
mussen kämpfen für unsere Zukunft
das ist nicht nur meine Meinung sie sind
als Reporter können Sie auf der Straße
zu gehen und einfach Menschen auf der
Straße zu fragen und ich bin mehr als
überzeugt jeder jeder gibt genau das
gleiche Antwort und dann ist noch eine
Frage wenn es jetzt einen
präsidentenwechsel geben würde in der
Ukraine was würde das für diesen Krieg
bedeuten selenski hat eine
wichtige Funktion als
Präsident
und deswegen Präsident zu wechsel jetzt
am Moment der
kriegzeit kanchellig sein das heißt bei
aller Kritik unterstützen sie schon
selenski Einigung das ist sehr sehr
wichtig für für die Ukraine in das Land
und außerhalb des Landes zu Anfang
standen stand die Mehrheit hinter diesem
Krieg ist das immer noch so wir kämpfen
gegen eine der stärkste und mächtigste
Armeen der Welt russische Armee und seit
Z Jahren wir verteidigen unser Land
erfolgreich verteidigen unseres Land
weil Putin hat seine Pläne nicht
realisiert das ist Sinn von diese
sinnlose Krieg noch
einmal Putin akzeptiert nicht unsere
Wunsch ein Teil von europäischeer
Familie zu werden siehtine als Teil der
russische imperie wir war schon in
russische imperie und wir wollen nicht
zurück in Vergangenheit wir sehen unsere
Zukunft als Teil von demokratische
europäische Familie dafür dafür kämpfen
wir jetzt habe ich auf ihrem
telegramkanal hier
gelesen da haben sie geschrieben dass
sie die ukrainische Demokratie doch
teilweise in Gefahr sehen dass die
Medien nicht mehr offen berichten können
dass sie das Gefühl haben dass die
Politik zentralisiert wird das ist ja
eine Kritik die sie da äußern wenn ich
sie richtig verstehe auch an Präsident
selenski der in der Welt als der da
steht der für die Demokratie und
Freiheit kämpft wie passt denn das
zusammen wir haben sehr viel gemacht in
vergangenen Jahren was betrifft Reformen
was betrifft Dezentralisierung was
betrifft die demokratische Werte aber
jetzt im Moment
zu sehen was läuft in andere Richtung
zentralisiert manche Politiker sagen
lass uns darüber nicht zu sprechen aber
nicht zu sprechen das bedeutet
anfstanden zu sein mit solche
undemokratische Aktivitäten und die
Frage wfür kämpfen wir
und zu schweigen das bedeutet
anverstanden zu sein deswegen dass es
man muss nicht als Kritik nehmen man
muss das als Empfehlung nehmen und fle
nicht zu machen weil unsere wichtigste
Wunsch die Werte europäische
demokratische Werte in okraine zu
realisieren und wo sehen sie da jetzt im
Moment konkret eine Gefahr dass diese
Werte in Frage gestellt werden oder wo
man etwas verändern muss wir sehen die
Konzentrierung auf macht
wir sehen die Dezentralisierung sogar
stattdezentralisierung als zentralisiert
wir seh alle centralisiert was betrift
Medi was
betri was Selbstverwaltung das ist sehr
viel Richtung und deswegen ich möchte
aufmerksam machen unsere Politik und
auch unsere Partner
das Gefahr haben sie mit Präsident
selenski darüber schon mal
gesprochen
nein sie sind der Bürgermeister von Kiev
einer der mächtigsten Politiker dieses
Landes und seit sind sie ja nicht von
selenski örtlich
entfernt leider habe ich keine
Gelegenheit gehabt mit
zelenski äh zu sprechen weil nach den
Anfang des Krieges haben wir keine
einzige Treff
gehabt woran liegt
das schwierig zu
erzählen darüber man kann viele
diskutieren aber denke ich mal dass ist
auch eine große fähle der Präsident das
ist eine Person wer muss
äh um sich den Menschen einigen und den
Menschen
motivieren anheit das ist die wichtigste
und die größte unsereer Stärke da ist
auch
Hintergrund eine politische Wettbewerb
ja diesen politischen Wettbewerb den
sehen wir jetzt aktiv und der hatte
natürlich auch Erstaunen
hervorgerufen können Sie mir erklären
was der Hintergrund
dessen ist dass der Präsident den
erfolgreichen Oberkommandierenden der
Armee absetzen will und der sich dann
weigert und ich sehe sie haben ein Bild
von Sal in Ihrem Regal da stehen also
haben sie gutes Verhältnis zu ihm was
betrifft er ist sehr beliebt sehr sehr
beliebt in Menschen bei
bevolkung und er Kommand von neu
Generation hat keine S Ausbildung solche
Figuren zu wechseln das ist ein fehle
von mein Sicht erwarten sie dass das
jetzt bald passiert oder
ähm ohne Feuer gibt kein Rauch was würde
das denn dann für den Kriegsverlauf
bedeuten
die Krieg ist zwei Jahre dauern ist kein
Geheimnis wir sind alle Menschen und
Leute sind müde und Soldaten auch
salus hat eine riesige Motivation er ist
ein Held in unseres Land unsere Schutze
und ihm zu absetzen jetzt im Moment
denke ich mal wird eine Fälle sind die
Soldaten zu lange an der Front es gibt
ja jetzt Proteste auch von Frauen vor
allen Dingen in der Ukraine die
sagen es muss eine neue
mobilisierungswelle geben es müssen neue
Leute an die Front kommen ist das für
die Ukraine noch machbar wir haben keine
andere Wahl mussen wir unsere Reserve
finden
ich sehe
keine Alternative jetzt im Moment
aufgeben ist keine Option für uns wir
mussen kämpfen das ist ja glaube ich der
Grundkonflikt zwischen der Ukraine und
vielen Menschen in Europa ich erlebe das
zumindest in meinen Gesprächen in
Deutschland dass manche sagen
es muss doch eine andere Option geben
wieso kämpft ihr weiter ja die Russen
sagen lass uns auf tich auf runde Tisch
zu setzen lass uns Kompromisse finden
lass lass uns eine Lösung finden ist
nicht fair eine Kompromisse zu finden
eine große Teil von
ine an
russenzugeben ist FA oder nicht J
Deutsch muss verstehen wir wir kämpfen
nicht nur für uns unsere Land und wir
schützen nicht unsere Familie und unsere
Städte wir schützen jede von euch und in
Kranke Vision von Putin Poland gehört
auch in russische imperie baltische
Lände und ihr deutsche mussen nicht
vergessen ein Teil von Deutschland in
Kranke Vision geht russische imperie
auch der der meine ich wo Putin
jahrelang als GGB Agent gearbeitet hat
und wenn wir stoppen nicht die Russland
ich schließe nicht aus er geht so weit
wie weit wir erlauben ihm zu
gehen ist schwierig zu verstehen das war
auch schwierig zu verstehen diese Krieg
kann anfangen in Mitte Europa meine ich
die
ukreine vor zi Jahren aber ist heute ist
leider harte Realität was denken Sie
haben die Deutschen denn noch nicht
verstanden dass immer noch diese
Debatten geführt werden was würden Sie
gerne dass sie noch verstehen das ein
Krieg gegen die Werte wir kämpfen für
unsere Werte für unsere Zukunft und der
jeder in Deutschland muss auch verstehen
dass ist eine Gefahr nicht für diean das
ist auch eine riesige Gefahr für
Europäische Union deswegen wir brauchen
noch zusätzliche Waffen ich möchte
betonen
Verteidigungswaffen weil wir verteidigen
unseres Land wir sind Ukraine war
niemals aggressiv gegen jemand heute
mussen wir unsere Land verteidigen und
möchte ich bedanken für
Waffen was bekommen wir aus Europa aus
Deutschland und wir brauchen mehr und
die Frage stellen ist reicht oder nicht
das reicht können dann sagen wenn der
Frieden kommt in unseres Land das
ist wichtig für uns und das ist wichtig
für Europa ich bewundere sie wenn sie
dann da stehen und sie haben das ja
schon so oft gemacht und wiederholen wir
brauchen die Waffen und dann sehen Sie
die politischen Prozesse die dauern und
dauern und dann wird darüber diskutiert
und hier sterben währenddessen Menschen
wie gehen Sie damit
um wir sind wir sind sehr dankbar für
Unterstützung der letzte Winter war die
schlimmste Winter und ich möchte sagen
dass es war eine volksmord uns
unsere burürge zu
lassen zu leben ohne Heizung Wasser
Elektrizität in Winter wenn draußen ist
- 200° Celsus das ist keine Krieg weil
sogar Krieg hat eine Regeln Frauen
Kinder alte Menschen Zivilisten nie
berühren und die Bilde von BU pel hat
die ganze Welt
schockiert wie man
kann Zivilisten wie man kann
Kinder Toten ohne rund und deswegen ich
nenne der Krieg
eine volksmord andere er braucht
ritorium er braucht uns nicht sie haben
das mehrfach gesagt dass sie das als
einen Genozid bezeichnen
ähm und dennoch
entschließt sich der Westen ihrer
Meinung
nach wirklich klar die Ukraine so mit
Waffen zu unterstützen wie sie das
erwarten
oder hat die Ukraine nicht was ist jetzt
mein Eindruck viel an Schlagkraft auch
verloren weil es so lange dauerte ich
meine es hat ja es hat ja Momente
gegeben da haben alle gesagt die Ukraine
kann jetzt Russland zurückdrängen sie
kann Territorium zurückerobern und dann
wurde wieder über Waffensysteme
diskutiert wie ist das aus ihrer
Perspektive sehr vi Politi in
Europa Zst viel langsam viel zu
versichtig haben eine riesige Respekt
und möchte nicht ein Teil von diese
Krieg zu werden aber die ganze Europa
schon ein Teil
und sehr viele Menschen in Europa schon
betroffen und von diese Krieg kann jeder
betroffen und deswegen jeder muss alles
was er kann machen diese Krieg zu
stoppen und Sanktion wirken sehr gut die
Waffenlieferung für die UK ist
notwendig
und Einigung um das zu keine das ist
eine Schlüssel für Frieden in Europa die
Frage die sich stellt ist auf was
richten Sie sich ein wie lange wird
dieser Krieg noch dauern wird der
schnell beendbar sein gibt es diese
Gedanken denken Sie darüber nach ich bin
keine wahrsage aber trotzdem kann
ich in Zukunft
schauen man man kann in vergang it
anschauen die alle Konflikten was
Russland
macht genau das gleiche Fingerabdrücke
Russland versteht nur die stärkere
Position wir mussen stark sein wir
mussen stark sein politisch in des
Landes wir müssen stark sein in der
Frontlinie wir mussen stark sein
wirtschaftlich sein wirtschaftlich und
einfach stark zu sein und deswegen
Einigung
in das Landes Einigung um das Landes um
der Ukraine das ist Wichti wichtigste
Schlüssel für der Erfolg für die Sieg
wie lange das wird dauern die Frage
stellt jede Ukraine und jeder wunscht
auf den Tag wenn Krieg vorbei ist das
ist die Traum für jede Ukraine aber
dafür man muss kämpfen für sein Trum
man muss kämpfen für seine Vision für
seine Zukunft für seine Familie für für
sein Land das machen wir weil haben wir
keine andere Wahl denken sie denn
darüber nach abzutreten als
Bürgermeister abzutreten also denken sie
über ihr Ende schon nach
oder manchmal manchmal wenn ich bin sehr
sehr Entschuldigung verdammt müde
und und keine Kraft
mehr hier in in mein Apartment dort in
in Fahrstuhl gibt eine Fenster und
schaue in meine Auge in die Spiegel in
die Spiegel
äh und frage ich mich
selbst du bist sicher brauchst du diese
Job aber nächste
Morgen bisschen erholt fahre ich mit
gleiche Fahrstuhl schaue ich in gleiche
Spiegel und sage
er gebe nicht auf wir rechnen mit ihnen
weiter als Bürgermeister von Kiev aber
sie sind jetzt sehr bescheiden gewesen
sie wissen ja schon dass sie auch
international ein wichtiger Politiker
sind für die Ukraine sie und selenski
sind überall aufgetreten wo man nur
auftreten konnte und ich glaube ohne sie
hätte es nicht so schnell diese breite
Unterstützung des Westens für die
Ukraine gegeben oder man
muss 100 prozentig konzentriert sein
hundertprozentig die seine Erfahrung
seine Wissen zu geben und nur dann wird
Ergebnis und wir rechnen auf gut
Ergebnis und die Frieden kommt wieder in
die ukine und wir kämpfen dafür jeden
Tag und jeden Tag wir sind wir stehen
auf mit einer Gedanke jeden Tag ist
wenige bis zum Sieg ist wenige bis zum
Kriegsende
äh das motiviert uns sehr und deswegen
kämpfen wir weiter für unsere Stadt für
unsere burürger für unsere Familie und
für unsere europäische Zukunft das ist
die klare Regeln
in meinem Motto ohne Kampf gibt kein
Sieg deswegen mussen wir
weitkämpfen ich wünsche Ihnen sehr dass
diese Tage nicht mehr so viele werden
dass es Frieden in der Ukraine gibt und
ich danke Ihnen für das Gespräch ja ich
Musch
[Musik]
besesag